[Musik]
guten Abend für den sportlichen Teil ist
Katja heute wieder bei mir ja einen
schönen guten Abend und wir blicken auf
die Themen an diesem
Sonntag weitere Geiseln freigelassen die
Hamas übergibt dem Roten Kreuz 17
Menschen Bundespräsident Steinmeier
trifft in Jerusalem Angehörige der
Geiseln karlsruh
parteitagsentscheidungen die Grünen
stellen sich für die Europawahl auf beim
streittha Asylrecht setzt sich die
Parteispitze
durch und gleich viermal auf dem Podest
das deutsche biathlonteam glänzt beim
Saisonauftakt in
Schweden ja wir beginnen die Sendung mit
dem inzwischen dritten Austausch von
Geiseln und Häftlingen zwischen Israel
und der Terrororganisation Hamas wieder
emotionale Momente die den Schmerz
vergangener Wochen kurz vergessen machen
nach längeren Verzögerung gestern lief
heute vergleichsweise reibungslos 14
israelische und drei ausländische
Geiseln wurden freigelassen 39
palästinensische Häftlinge sollen folgen
mehr von Dominik
lmeister der dritte Tag der
geiselfreilassung Hamas hat dem Roten
Kreuz 14 Israelis und drei Ausländer
übergeben darunter viele Kinder eine
84-jährige wurde mit dem Hubschrauber
ins Krankenhaus gebracht gestern Freude
bei Emilys Vater er dachte sie sei tot
doch das neunjährige irischisraelische
Mädchen ist unter den
freigelassenen im Gegenzug ließ Israel
gestern weitereen 39 palästinensische
Häftlinge aus Gefängnissen frei Freude
darüber im
Westjordanland der Bundespräsident am
Abend in Jerusalem Treffen mit
israelspräsidenten Herzog Steinmeier
erinnert an den Terror der Hamas vom 7
Oktober nichts ist
vergessen nicht die Erlebnisse
derjenigen die ihre Angehörigen verloren
haben und wir vergessen nicht die
Berichte und Bilder aus den ersten
Tagen nach dem 7 Oktober nach dem
brutalen
terrorüberfall der
Hamas zuvor hatte der Bundespräsident
begleitet von Bundestagspräsidentin bas
die Angehörigen deutsch-israelischer
Entführungsopfer besucht sie fordern
Unterstützung vom
Bundespräsidenten die Hauptaufgabe sein
bis alle freigekommen
sind bis morgen bleibt der
bundespräsidenttin Israel ein Zeichen
der Solidarität
Deutschlands wir gehen live nach Tel
Aviv zu l walport lüg dreimal hat es
jetzt einen ja erfolgreichen Austausch
gegeben wie geht's jetzt
weiter also die Vereinbarung und die
damit verbundene Feuerpause gilt bis
morgen im Prinzip würden also morgen die
die letzten Geiseln freikommen und dann
so hat die israelische Seite mehrfach
betont werde eigentlich der Krieg wieder
aufgenommen man hat aber eine Hintertür
offen gelassen sollte die Hamas sich
bereit erklären weitere jeweils zehn
Geiseln mindestens täglich freizulassen
dann könnte die Feuerpause um ein bis
zwei bis 3 Tage verlängert werden und
darüber wird verhandelt hinter den
Kulissen zwischen den Vermittlern Qatar
USA Ägypten mit den beiden
Kriegsparteien und
US-Präsident Biden hat nach einem
Telefonat mit dem israelischen
Regierungschef Netanyahu heute
angekündigt er sei für eine Verlängerung
wenn dafür weitere Geiseln freikämen
kurze Zeit später meldete sich auch die
has über Nachrichtenagenturen zu Wort
und hat gesagt man könne zwei bis vier
Tage dran hängen und dann bis zu 40
weitere Geiseln freilassen wie gesagt
beschlossen ist nichts aber darüber wird
gerade verhandelt LÜK vielen Dank für
die
Information Russland meldet ukrainische
Drohnenangriffe mindestens Objekte habe
die Flugabwehr rund um die Hauptstadt
Moskau und drei anderen Gebieten
abgeschossen hieß es aus dem russischen
Verteidigungsministerium einige Gebäude
wurden beschädigt Informationen zu
opfern gab es nicht in der Nacht zuvor
hatte Russland die Ukraine mit mehr als
60 Drohnen
angegriffen der Präsident des
Arbeitgeberverbandes reiner Dulger geht
davon aus dass Deutschland wegen des
Fachkräftemangels an Wohlstand einbüßen
wird der Bild am Sonntag sagte er die
Politik müsse versuchen das abzumildern
dafür müsse Deutschland für Fachkräfte
aus dem Ausland wieder attraktiv werden
außerdem kritisierte Dulger die
Klimapolitik als schädlich für den
Wirtschaftsstandort dass die
Durchsetzung von klimaschutzinteressen
aktuell mit mehr Widerständen verbunden
ist registrieren auch die Grünen auf
ihrem Parteitag in karlsruhr wurde das
ebenso intensiv debattiert wie das Thema
Asyl und Migration heute zum Finale des
Parteitag ging noch mal um die
Europawahl im kommenden Sommer Andreas
Huppert Aufbruch Richtung Europa die
Liste der grünen Abgeordneten für die
Europawahl im nächsten Jahr sie steht
die Spitzenkandidatin weiß die Zeiten
sind nicht einfach für grüne ökologische
Politik also lst uns jetzt nicht
aufgeben lasst uns kämpfen kämpfen dafür
dass wir noch größer werden im
Europäischen Parlament kämpfen das
musste in der Nacht auch die
Parteispitze denn die Grüne Jugend hatte
einen Antrag zur Abstimmung gestellt der
alle Ministerinnen und Minister alle
Abgeordneten verpflichten sollte keine
asylrechtsverschärfung zuzustimmen weder
in Deutschland noch in Europa es gibt
keinen Grund für weitere
asylrechtsverschärfung insofern ist die
Wahrheit dass dieser Antrag auffordert
die Regierung zu verlassen nach
stundenlanger Diskussion und Streit wird
der Antrag abgelehnt die Parteiführung
hat sich durchgesetzt wir wussten die
ganze Zeit das System gibt die diese
Partei beschäftigen die sehr
leidenschaftlich diskutiert werden und
haben miteinander dementsprechend die
üblichen Diskussionen geführt und haben
klare Entscheidung getroffen die wir
geschlossen tragen vier Tage Parteitag
42 Stunden Debatte den Vorstand neu
gewählt die Europaliste aufgestellt
undter Streit Thema Migration abgeräumt
das Unbehagen der Basis bei den
Kompromissen die die Grünen in der
ampelregierung machen müssen das konnte
der Parteitag sicherlich nicht
ausräumen im Norden von Indien sitzt
seit 2 Wochen 41 Arbeit in einem
eingestürzten
autobahntunnelfest das Unglück ereignete
sich nach einem Erdrutsch und eigentlich
gab es schon Hoffnung auf Befreiung aber
technische Probleme verzögern jetzt die
Rettung Lena sünderbruch mit mehr dieser
Mann hart vor dem Tunnel aus wartet
darauf dass sein 22-jähriger Sohn mjit
gerettet wird ich werde ihn niemals
wieder zur Arbeit in den Tunnel schicken
ich möchte dass er den Beruf wechselt
und nie wieder zurückgeht
die Gegend hier im Norden Indiens ist
anfällig für Erdbeben und
Überschwemmungen immer wieder kommt es
so zu Erdrutschen ein schwerer Bohrer
sollte die Trümmer durchbrechen er hat
sich festgefressen nun müssen sie sich
per Hand mit kleinem Werkzeug durch
mehrere Meter Schutt und geröllgraben
bis das gelingt werden die
eingeschlossenen über Rohre mit Essen
Wasser und Medikamenten versorgt sie
haben an Angehörige durchgegeben dass es
ihnen gut geht die Rettungsaktion wird
sich hinziehen ein Experte Mut dass die
Verschütteten noch einige weitere Wochen
durchhalten müssen womöglich bis
Weihnachten Wintereinbruch in Osteuropa
an diesem Wochenende Rumänien Serbien
und Bulgarien wurden von den
ungewöhnlichen intensiven Schneefällen
überrascht in Rumänien sorgten
Schneestürme und Verwehungen für Chaos
in rund 400 Ortschaften fiel der Strom
aus in Bulgarien ist bei eisiger Kälte
ein Obdachloser Mann erfroren
Landstraßen waren aufgrund der
Schneemassen unbefahrbar abgebrochene
Äste blockierten vieler Orts die
Fahrbahnen und jetzt zum Sport und zu
den deutschen Erfolgen beim Biathlon in
Östersund Schweden Franziska Prus hat
sich nach langer ein nach langer
Krankheitspause eindrucksvoll
zurückgemeldet wurde im Einzel mit 0,1
Sekunden Rückstand zweite vor
Teamkollegin Vanessa Vogt seinen ersten
Weltcup Sieg bejubelte bei den Männern
Roman
re damit hat keiner gerechnet den
deutschen Biathleten gelingt ein
sensationeller Doppelerfolg Roman Rees
gewinnt das Einzelrennen vor seinem
Teamkollegen Justus strelo Topfavorit
Johannes tingisbö kämpft wird nach zwei
schießfelern aber nur Dritter die zwei
deutschen Athleten leisten sich in dem
Rennen auf der schweren Strecke in
Östersund je nur eine Strafminute der
30-Jährige re feiert den ersten
Weltcupsieg seiner Karriere für strelo
ist es der erste Podestplatz in einem
Einzelrennen ja und auch wieder auf dem
Podium ist ein deutscher Skispringer in
kusamo Finnland gelandet dieses Mal
Andreas Wellinger auf Rang 3 nach dem
ersten Sprung war Wellinger noch
Sechster dann flog er auf 146 m die
zweitbeste tagesweite war das vor ihm
die Österreicher Stefan Kraft und Jan
Hörl hinter ihm zwei DSV Teamkollegen
Pius Paschke und Stefan
lei Fußball buundesligistunion Berlin
hat einen neuen Trainer der Kroate
nenard biitza wird Nachfolger von Urs
Fischer
der neue an der Alten Försterei eine
Überraschung und ein alter Bekannter in
der Liga habe mir immer gewünscht zurück
nach Bundesliga zu kommen und beim so
ein Verein zu arbeiten wie Union Berlin
noch mehr Mitte November die Trennung
von aufstiegstrainer Urs Fischer Union
aktuell seit 15 Pflichtspielen sieglos
nun also nenard bjelizer 3 Jahre Spieler
bei Kaisers Lautern als Trainer mit
Austria Wien und Dinamo sagreb in der
Champions League mit Union geht's zum
Start nach Braga und Samstag zu den
Bayern und noch dies bei Formel 1 Pilot
Max Verstappen gehen in dieser Saison
fast die Superlative aus er gewann auch
den letzten Saison Grand Prix in Abu
Dhabi damit stand er in 19 von 22 Rennen
ganz oben auf dem Podium
einvum zudem wurde er mit dem größten
Vorsprung der Geschichte zum dritten Mal
nacheinander Weltmeister da kann man
schon mal durchdrehen die das immer
machen müssen na ja gut danke schön wir
blicken noch gemeinsam aufs Wetter meist
trüb mit Regen oder Schnee teils bis in
die tiefen Lagen im Westen zeitweise
kräftiger und böhiger Wind die
Höchstwerte dann zwischen 0 und
6° um
21:45 Uhr ordnet Christian Sievers die
Nachrichtenlage im heutejournal für sie
ein jetzt geht's um die Folgen des 60
Milliarden Lochs für die Ampel in Berlin
direkt mit Diana Zimmermann guten Abend